[Aplausos]
boa noite
outros eu agradeço muito o convite de
sua organização em particular e da amiga
susana anos cabeça força do tratamento e
do compromisso e não pude me mandar
também um abraço outro amigo pedro
baganha e colega que eu gostei muito da
organização com grande generosidade
lutava bom mas sim do ju que o motivo
que me convidaram eu estar aqui tem a
ver com aquilo que temos vindo a fazer
nem nasce da fé e fizemos só pra você
encontrar novamente
fizemos coisas muito pouco visíveis como
por exemplo o estado das culturas do do
palácio da bolsa
o restauro ea reabilitação de bairros
sociais trabalho durante muitos anos
muitos colegas não apreciava muito nós
desde sempre achamos muito interessante
e com grande impacto na vida das pessoas
uma vez mais sem grande visibilidade e
com grande impacto por deus
fizemos coisas mais visíveis como por
exemplo a ampliação da do da escola
francesa do porto e neste enquadramento
muito sensível diz house e santos 1 do
edifício também extraordinário dos anos
fizemos também o 1º centro de apoio a
imigrantes no porto o centro são seriam
numa altura em que este tema estado
bater tanto nós criarmos o email do
programa do país em portugal de
acolhimento grandes intervenções no
jardim botânico do porto nesta casa as
estufas pela casa só uma vez e ganhamos
algum reconhecimento como este o prêmio
da amada neste edifício do marcos da
silva e também com provavelmente em
ambos o prêmio nacional de reabilitação
urbana também com casas alagadas no
jardim botânico
mas ganhamos novamente ser branco somos
nós também os responsáveis pelo atual
projeto do do mercado do bolhão
não vou falar de nenhum destes projectos
porque eu me parece será muito mais
interessante está com uma maneira de
perceber como é que se constroem uma
idéia uma proposta da arquitetura e
juízes tido muitas vezes está onde vêm
as idéias para fazer um projeto difícil
uma assistente e e eu julgo que há
pessoas que sabem exatamente onde e por
que te faz há outras que não sabem muito
bem acho que esta é uma ideia iluminada
que vem do céu é e artistas
em alguns casos havia um caminho que não
funcionava e alguém dizer pois foi
desenhador que tem muito é muito bonito
mas não funciona
e é uma coisa que está bastante
habituado a ouvir é preciso o trabalho
ser normalmente muito mais um trabalho
de simples do que propriamente um
trabalho de mera iluminação e de
inspiração e no entanto eu diria kt a
principal matéria prima do nosso
trabalho
são as circunstâncias circunstância o
tempo complementar o nosso mestre da
escola do porto utilizava e que de fato
é muito é muito eficaz para a
circunstância nossa matéria prima e as
circunstâncias históricas temporais
físicas sociais simbólicas inspiração
nós temos o primeiro campus mostra e
voltar só o flash para não amassar a
capela do crew que fizemos com o centro
dirigido pelos jesuítas aqui no porto
era uma vez um buraco num canto do
jardim então lá dentro dois edifícios
muito pouco de santos e desde logo muito
interessante que a proposta tinha que
anular aquele buraco e que era uma
capela tem grande possibilidade dos dois
edifícios khan foi de nossas costas que
aproveitar se da geometria que resultava
visto que era quase uma abstração e que
tem essa força simbólica que é possível
uma pessoa se olhar ao espelho antes de
entrar
caiu estava nos perfeitamente primeiros
15 por tratar-se máquina nos trabalhos
assim um tema à volta do qual nós víamos
se diziam amigos e conversamos e
maturana e pois todo o nosso trabalho é
um trabalho de tentar resolver isso com
maior de candidatos possíveis problemas
construtivos problemas teve os problemas
de segurança feita sem perder esta
intenção e esta poesia
o papel tinha também está instalado deve
chover ao longo do das sessões do ano
este cenário a vida é passado
uma capela dias e libertar a vida e não
em virada para dentro
e curiosamente dois anos depois andamos
nós a chave correta que após descobrir
que esta artista plástica o tangram
desde os anos 60 andava a trabalhar a
questão este tema da reflexão e do corpo
no espaço foi detido esta presença
diversas dentro do mesmo espaço seus
múltiplos poderão ser observados trio
está no interior e esta permanente
diluição do com fini do limite e fato
damos nosso foco é realmente nossa chapa
e descobrimos a pólvora e as pessoas a
pensar nisto há muito mais tempo que nós
e à volta destas questões e de sistemas
a forma de estudar bilhão foi construído
e nas proximidades e e as analogias com
a capela destas duas faces do papai noel
traga outro projeto que gosto muito
porque parte de uma espécie de
insensibilidade e será acesa goianiense
e no porto a sessão cristã da mocidade
transformava por uma dupla louca de
francesa em 2007 num numa confecção
artesanal tais teu uma dupla boca porque
se for um fato visionários perceber que
o porto era um espaço altamente mutável
fantástico 20 minutos do aeroporto ainda
com sawa a fé artesanal pode fazer
confecção têxtil e propuseram esta este
caminho inverso que a confecção estava a
fazer posterior da cidade
propuseram dentro da cidade e dentro de
si difícil maravilhoso curso foca e este
será o salão que nós encontramos no
interior quem estava um bocadinho o
feitosa isto era eu era um clube inglês
e protestantes é a sala dava tanto pouco
tempo contava para as festas e esta eu
precisava de espaço precisavam do espaço
físico para pôr as máquinas e tapou os
50 para colocar os 50 postos de trabalho
que eles iriam criar algo notável no
centro da cidade
o regresso de uma função como esta é a
50 porte trabalho investimento
estrangeiro
nós temos que fazer tudo o que estiver
ao nosso alcance para o fato não deixe
de ir embora mantendo tanto quanto
possível do edifício e assim foi
e para esta foi a mesa limpa nós
propusemos
em contraponto à mesa inexistente no
salão como a geometria de frente é
possível algum dia se quisermos e que
muita vezes vim a descobrir também mais
tarde
com este trabalho cirurgia que não é
inimigo down faz nas suas instalações
fotográficas e os pacientes dentro e eu
chamo a atenção esta delicadeza como é
que no m
as imagens encontrando pontos de
coincidência com os passes existentes
por cento com que as imagens introduzem
dentro do espaço ampliações a é muito
sutil é a relação mas é muito mas é
muito incerto
é como uma uma imagem introduzida no
espaço o palco delatar que ocultava
também dizia muitas vezes é é uma
transformação da continuidade
e esta hein isto é algo que eu acho que
também caracteriza a nossa escola escola
do porto nem atuar e transformar na
continuidade à festa e outra imagem
mutável parem como surpresa da
continuação do caminho entre o deste
lado e como nós temos ali também nesta
proposta este ponto explicação estamos
sempre atuar ligando incluindo invitável
mente
esta é uma imagem final e esta é uma
imagem que eu gosto muito
dentro do um salão seco são 9 50 postos
de trabalho vai funcionar numa vida nova
dentro do edifício
este outro centro universitário que
construímos em coimbra e uma casa ar
novo 1929 esta imagem já comprava
despedir da casa manter apesar de ter
que mexer porque também o centro de
estudo universitário ter que mexer nas
suas funções que ela tivesse um caráter
de casa
esta é uma capela que produzimos no
último piso e aqui convoca outros um
grande artista plástico guarda
matta-clark um homem que viveu muito
pouco tempo ele morreu muito novo e fase
esta dentro de edifícios existentes
abria
este passo é um um novo limite um novo
com fim de forma geométrica eu no fundo
dava nos a ler respectivas no interior
dos edifícios que antes não nos tínhamos
apercebido que existia e quando atuamos
numa pré existência muito do nosso
trabalho e é esse
esta já é uma imagem do do centro em
coimbra é da nova relação que criamos
entre a cozinha salas de apoio para
criar um uso mais flexível de forma como
ficou
não existe esta cultura e esta é uma
nova sala criada ao fundo concordou sala
de onde é retirada esta imagem
e esta trapalhada que foi aberta na na
capela para o jardim da sereia e para
terminar tacos mais dois mas duas
situações um bocadinho diferente aqui
vocês viram a tec atuações onde por
força da nossa reflexão posterior à obra
encontramos analogias com o trabalho de
artistas plásticos de fato os artistas
plásticos cineastas os escritores não
muito à frente e este é um caso
diferente e quando arquitetura também
uma plataforma dá uma de norma traz de
chicle na área da sabem que para fazer
uma tão essencial uma casinha nós
precisamos obter a câmera cerca de 11
projetos diferentes e eo arquiteto o
homem da synthes que sintetiza todos
estes conhecimentos de diferentes e eu
sempre posso trazer esta instituição
o projeto então esta casa travou esta
casa porque os barra é um grande
chicana política é nesta casa tem esta
famosa china que constem todos os
manuais de arquitetura que o meu filho
o joão quando visitamos a casa em 2009 e
e eu era muito próximo do churrasco um
artista plástico mexicano que tem este
famoso esta famosa obra também gaúcho
rosa sobre fundo azul ea china é a
famosa piscina do hr é uma classe
transposição direta desta desta pintura
deus comunicavam muito e fizeram vários
ensaio juntos e nós no jardim botânico
na casa saber por força de uma relação
tão próxima que temos tido com quantas
plásticas e nomeadamente com gêmeos luiz
o famoso ilustrador escultor designer
podemos transformar esta é pouco
interessante casa dos casais diz jardim
botânico como está o território em
garagens na casa uma casa do estudo é um
milagre nem café no fundo de estudantes
da universidade do porto estão passar
alguns passos para dentro mas algumas
imagens do interior
estou antes e este é o já muito pouco
valor fomos buscar aquilo que tinha
valor uma obra muito econômica muito
contida com muito pouco em área mas luiz
permitiu de que a casa tem assim uma
dimensão que transcenda a si próprio
porque em conjunto conosco a desenhar
aguarda o corrimão deste espaço como na
forma de uma escultura um animal uma
espécie de uma lama praia que assinala e
tim lopes sai da casa com você estou a
ver que afinal a entrada na própria casa
na casa anderson caso do ovo da sophia
mello braga e isso foi muito mais
escurecido porque de facto é um
privilégio porque tem tanto poder
concretizar uma uma profecia poética e
porque que isto aconteceu porque são
imagens da casa quando ela reabriu ao
público em 2010 para receber a exposição
do tarot em uma escada nova que tivemos
que introduziria escada original
as estufas justamente maravilhosas dos
anos trinta do francês cop que foram
recuperadas
falei mas apenas visita a sofia como
vocês sabem feitos à casa e aos jardins
frequentemente em toda a sua obra é
escrever via a casa e concretamente
pátio central estátua central onde
aconteciam os básicos quatro serão tem
uma tecnologia muito interessante esta
casa grande
pouco comum no porto um espaço central
com os passos os restantes espaços
circundantes isso fia descrevia na saga
na história da terra e do mar
escrevi este espaço tudo na casa era
discutida há muito grande desde 4 de
dormir nas crianças andavam de bicicleta
até ao normativo e pro o qual davam
todas as salas e no qual como hanes
dizia se poderia armar o esqueleto da
baleia que há anos já usava empacotado
em numerosos volumes nas caves da
fundação da faculdade de ciências por
não ouvir ou haver lugar onde convencer
a irmã
pois é verdade é que a baleia estava no
museu de história natural de facto
conseguimos restaurá-la recuperá lá e
voltar a trazê-la para o átrio da casa
anderson e
foi já foi a primeira interpretação da
saga das histórias da terra e do mar de
sophia da linha do douro em lacado estão
a ver ali já causa da balaia e rolaria
voltou ao espaço onde as fia e de fato
profetizado que ela se calhar um dia
está com esta concretização que acontece
uma vez na vida o arquiteto de uma
profecia poética
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]